[Musique]
alors le tournage des rpg 3 c'était
certainement un de nos plus gros
tournages depuis le mass effect
d'ailleurs depuis trois jours donc c'est
c'est pas si vieux que ça au début c'est
sûr que c'est venu d'une blague en fait
c'était la scor sortie de skyrim
il me semble c'est en 2011 fin 2011 et
on pensait au tour foussereau darphin
qui avait dans les pubs et ou du jeu on
pensait fils de parce que c'était rigolo
de voir le joueur du grenier qui hurlent
qui dit des gros mots et voilà donc
thématique médiévale fantastique en
récusant tizi donc skyrim donc tout
s'emboîte est parfaitement avec les
coûts de belote
déjà la base on voulait on voulait
qu'ils aient des guest on voulait pas
qu'ils aient des guest pour qu'ils aient
des guest mai mais c'est juste que ça me
fait plaisir ça me fait plaisir de
tourner à il écopait en plus on n'avait
jamais tourné avec avec mathieu n'avait
jamais tourné avec bing ce donc y'a bob
qui revient évidence qui était dans le
cast original et on voulait rajouter
encore d'autres gens parce qu'on voulait
vraiment faire un effet communauté on
voulait vraiment faire comme s'ils
aventure avancée pour cette vidéo du
coup c'était un peu spécifique parce que
c'était la première fois qu'on faisait
appel à une personne qui réalise
carrément notre place à ornette déjà
fait appel à des personnes qui nous
aident à tenir la caméra venons lui on
me dit tu fais ta le talent de caméras
etc avec nous pendant ce temps leur base
devant la caméra notamment pour les rpg
2 mais là c'était la première fois
vraiment on a fait venir quelqu'un ou
lui a dit voilà voilà le scénario
voilà à peu près le storyboard veulent à
peu près les plans qu'on imagine
vaguement s'adapter aussi sur les lieux
de tournage c'est ça aussi le défi parce
que nous on a story board et des trucs
qu'on avait on avait un espèce de guide
mais après c'est une fois qu'on arrive
sur les lieux se placer la caméra y'a un
champ contrechamp faut pas oublier qu'un
personnage qui rentre ça c'est vraiment
le genre de questions ou vraiment les
gens qui ont l'habitude de faire des
vidéos que savent se dévoyer trouver des
solutions et sur cinq tomes voilà c'est
super bien débrouillé
pour links aussi donc alexis on a fait
appel a en effet pas la lui d'accepter
de celui qui était ravi de participer
moi j'avais un peu peur qu'ils veuillent
pas porter son il n'assume pas son rôle
de lutins alors qu'en fait il a
parfaitement su on lui a donné le
costume il a enfilé sa dans la rue il se
baladait avec mais sans aucun problème
devant des gens qu'il regardait il a
même fait des photos avec des gens je
crois c'est vraiment il a abandonné sa
fierté extrêmement lite bon pour moi ça
a été le tournant de chaussures il a
complètement assumé son rôle des fils a
complètement adoré ça pue la fois que je
fais mais c'était chouette c'était bien
et puis il avait appris son texte aussi
c'est surtout il avait appris les parker
les répliques en belgique pour bien les
ressortir du premier coup et c'était
vraiment quel professionnalisme parce
que nous on ne vit pas du tout à fait
notre texte dont on n'apprend jamais
d'un texte on arrive on lit la ligne
avant de last hit de la ressortir et
cube obstacles et lui il avait vraiment
tout appris le texte en venant donc il
avait vraiment fait les choses
impeccable tout carré avant de venir
avec les gars c'était hyper adorable
enfin voila c'est le collègue de youtube
donne
et tout ça me gratte de famille à de
youtube vraiment ils sont vraiment super
cool et source à l'anecdote c'est que
bob dormait à la maison et il commentait
le 3 parce qu'il fait ça chaque année
donc le truc c'est que le 3 ça se passe
en californie à los angeles
donc décalage horaire donc il devait
rester éveillés jusqu'à 3h 4h du mat
pour voir les conférences de sony
microsoft tout ça et du coup mais il a
quand même fait du coup c'est à dire
qu'il faisait des nuits blanches
littéralement où il s'est couché
à 6 heures du mat et il se devait 7h30
donc il avait une heure de sommeil est
donc entre chaque prise envoyait bob
effondrée par terre en train de dormir
quelque part il a dormi partout il a
dormi dans un camp à côté d'eux à côté
de l'auberge où on attendait on
attendait la scène de l'auberge il a
dormi dans la forêt tels john snow
replié avec sa couverture et sa fourrure
comme ça parce qu'on peut retenir c'est
que voilà bob je te tire mon chapeau
parce que j'ai jamais vu un mec
enfin comme il dit il burst en fait
voilà c'est il trouve les l'énergie
qu'en cas il faut dès qu'on lui dit
action en balance sa réplique tak goo me
rends dans le personnage
ce soir le truc nickel il joue bien donc
voilà bob respect infini
ensuite concernant mathieu aussi mathieu
qui jouent super bien aussi franchement
à une bonne ribambelle de bons acteurs
france pour le coup voilà je veux pas
cirer les pompes
ils ont tous assuré et puis ils ont même
proposé des trucs genre mathieu la scène
de la taverne dans la crêperie c'est lui
qui a proposé enfin qui a modifié
légèrement la phrase genre la réplique
dans le texte était merde on m'a volé
mes pompes
voilà c'était ça et il a rajouté le en
corse c'est un petit détail mais je
trouve que ça rajoute un il ya une
notion enfin un côté humoristique
supplémentaires sur le fait que le
hobbit se fasse tout en taxi ses pompes
je trouve ça rigolo
visionnaire une dernière
ou alors aussi par exemple sur la scène
du château où on arrivait qu'on voit les
ohrid les oreilles de links qui sont au
sol il a la rage il en a rajouté
énormément derrière en faisant le par
exemple le halo qui fait ça y est t'es
pas et ils vont la laisser au montage du
coup parce que c'était extrêmement
heureux et franchement c'est steurs
égalise je suis parent bien un petit l'a
amené lui-même son costume c'est le
costume qu'il avait aux geeks ferries
avec ses petites babouche ces petites
babouche qui vend qui vont à l'envers
comme ça c'était c'est très rigolo
et puis aussi évidemment faut pas
oublier de remercier shon geek qui est
la costumière officiel qui nous fait
tous les costumes dans les idées j'ai
kiffé les goûts et tous les costumes et
en fait les costumes d'alpha cinq
costumes de terminator les costumes des
rpg 2 les costumes des rpg 3 voilà elle
a passé énormément de temps à faire les
costumes elle a fait du super boulot
vraiment nos costumes sont magnifiques
ils rentrent super bien à l'écran et
donc on lui fait un gros bisou et c'est
aussi la fille qu'on voit jouer l'elfe
dans la vidéo et qui s'en prend plein la
gueule
tournage au château c'était c'était un
peu délicat dans le sens où le château
était ouvert au public
donc voilà on a dû tourner au milieu des
gens mais et au milieu des travaux aussi
c'est ça le problème c'est que pile à
l'endroit on devait tourner la scène de
la tour donc la scène de fait un mailing
d'autres avec une scie circulaire vous
et ça résonnait puisque c'était une
enceinte en pierre donc c'était une
magnifique caisse de résonance ballon et
ça s'est tournée après mes entretiens
officiels avec mon micro ben j'aurais du
mal à enlever tous à d'autres je pense
qu'on est parti tout retour au doublé au
bosphore
c'était compliqué parce que là on avait
vraiment besoin de son pouvait pas tout
redoublé après enfin on l'aurait fait
sans doute mais voilà c'était important
d'avoir une bonne prise de sont donc les
gars ont été super cool avec nous les
ouvriers à chaque fois qu'on disait
qu'on tournait enfin on les prévenir
juste avant donc il s'arrête devant une
petite pause le temps qu'on enregistre
et donc après on les prenne des cancans
c'était fini puis ils pouvaient repartir
dos et donc on a pu faire ce qu'on
voulait faire et on les en remercie pour
les bisons et donc pour cette vidéo je
suis bien content qu'on ait été les
premiers à le faire c'est on avait des
drones en avait des plans en drones et
ça rendait super bien et franchement ça
a tout de suite de la gueule et pour les
mêmes ce qu'ils apparaissent même si
elle n'a que quatre dans toute la vidéo
ça rend extrêmement bien je les remercie
je remercie
dominique et son collègue qui sont venus
de votre savoie c'est les drones capture
système je leur fait de la pub parce que
vraiment ils sont ils sont super gentils
d'être venus d'aussi loin pour nous
aider grâce à eux on a pu faire des
super plan brawn pour l'intro et aussi
pour la conclusion ce plan où la caméra
s'éloigne comme ça c'est pas un zoom
mais c'est maintenant un plan en drones
moi je vous rappel du dernier plan en
grande qu'on a fait avec le gros drone
le rouge et noir enfin le mastoc quoi
vraiment le bourg de compet
on l'a fait sur la fin de la batterie du
drone c'est à dire voilà tous les
gyrophares sa cliente et de partout ça
bip et le truc c'était la fin de la
batterie c'était le dernier plan que
vous pouvez faire avec et dominique qui
pilotait le drone était un peu en
panique parce que enfin moi sur le coup
je réalisais pas j'ai plus de batterie
tu remets une batterie et c'est bon mais
oui mais le truc qu'il est en vol il et
je vois combien de mètres dans les airs
et il ya peut-être des gens qui
pourraient passer en dessous et se faire
décapiter broyer s'évanouir parce que au
niveau batterie ok mais non je pense
qu'elle va bien travailler pas mal mais
mais pour le coup ça a rendu la scène un
peu intense quoi c'est à dire moi
j'étais avec mon téléphone portable et
fred qui étaient là haut qui était caché
dans la tour en fait qui parlait à linz
pour dire où la vase hisser le moment
vas-y mon trottoir machin on a galéré on
a fait plein de prises est la dernière
chose que la toute dernière oui et puis
batterie autonomie qui désigne
maintenant faut se poser faut arrêter
c'était la bonne et si c'est le corps et
me paraît vidéo donc c'était chaud in
extremis mais au final c'est réussi donc
pour les cocktails d'ailleurs je pense
qu'il ya des habitants de fougères qui
ont dû se poser des questions notamment
le plan ou ligne c'était en haut de la
tour dont qui était une qui était une
parodie d'un plan de même tant redouter
une reprise du plan de sacré graal il
était filmé par drones serre qu'il avait
vraiment le drone qui était à 60 mètres
de lui
et qui s'avançait vers lui et il m'avait
dit que ça le faisait à ses filles parce
que le drone était quand même un gros
machin un truc qui vraiment qui est
vraiment impressionnant c'est pas le
petit drone comme ça c'était le gros
drones legros drones voilà du coup
les habitants qui devait le voir de loin
ce que la tour du château se voit de
tout le village et des habitants qui
devait voir un mec déguisé en elfe avec
un drone pierre qui se dirigent qui
dirigera lui enfin alpha en lutin donc
ça doit être assez rigolo et laura ling
comment s'est passée ta tour
héros de nos décomptes
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote on a failli
avoir des problèmes avec ça on a failli
avoir des problèmes parce que je pense
sané gaza n'est qu'une théorie ça n'est
qu'une théorie mais quand on a fait le
plan en drones dans le château avec
links donc quelques dizaines de minutes
plus tard on a un hélico de la
gendarmerie qui nous a survolé on avait
déjà tout on avait déjà tout ranger
un hélico de la gendarmerie qui nous est
passé au-dessus repasser une deuxième
fois au dessus
je me demande ça n'est qu'une théorie
mais je me demande si c'était pas pour
nous mêmes
je pense que c'est pour nous parce que
quand même l'hélico il nous est passé
deux fois au dessus en tournant en rond
donc il n'y avait personne d'autre que
nous donc mais après que quand ils ont
vu qu'on était juste quand ils ont vu le
costume de ligne je pensais sont durs et
c'est moi c'est pas l'éternité
et puis link the sun et nous gratifie
d'un film sur la gauche dans les autres
anecdotes aussi on a tourné un plan qui
n'est pas du tout utilisé qui est à la
fin quand qu'en ligne s'est affalé par
terre après que nous on s'en prennent on
s'en va après le plan de fin dominique
qui pilote les drones s'est amusé à
faire quelques plans en rab où on voit
donc ligne s'allonger par terre avec la
caméra qui zoome sur lui à la façon d'un
d'une mort dans gta vous savez westhead
qui apparaît c'est on l'a pas utilisé
finalement mais c'était assez drôle ce
qu'en fait on voulait on avait même eu
l'idée de faire en sorte que le lapin
qui était à ce moment là assis sur lui
triomphalement s'en aille avec le avec
le avec les listes du drone un moment le
cancale drones se rapproche de lexique
qui était comme ça qui philippe est
vraiment ce qu'il avait vraiment le
drone à 3 cm au dessus du que le lap s
en aille avec avec le vent mais bon ça
rendait pas terrible ce que google
appelle rouler vos ouailles mais on
voyait bien que
vends des turbines du drone qui le
pousse et encore il ya aussi le fait
qu'on devait tourner la fameuse scène
avec les elfes le roi des elfes l'iphone
sylvain donc links mais aussi ses
sous-fifres quoi donc on est sur le
tournage avec tout le monde
équipe est prêt à tourner caméra
batterie tom chaud bouillant en appel
flèche en fait on a des archers qui
banques dans lui de plainfaing donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait on est dans une
forêt il ya des bouts de bois aller en
improvise tak tak donc tout le monde est
parti récupérer des branches pour
laisser trouver un truc
voilà hyper plat hyper long qui ferait
office de flèches ensuite dit ouais mais
les flèches ce n'est pas juste et bout
doit il faut aussi des pointes de vent
donc comment on fait récupère la canette
de coca c'était trop d'en essayer de
faire des petits triangles convoi
plierait tac tac en ami à vous et ça
passe nickel au final ça passe
impeccable alors le problème c'est qu'on
n'a pas de flèches du cou on essaie de
bricoler des fleuves sont à chercher des
bastons qu'ils font à ses droits dans le
bois de ses toiles en train de fabriquer
se met à travailler juste faire des
pointes c'est donc on essaie de se
débrouiller mais c'est comme ça dans les
tournages la qualité numéro un c'est la
débrouille pour le coup je pense que
toutes les personnes qui étaient témoins
sur le tournage ont pu s'apercevoir à
quel point on était à larache et
complètement et mais ils ont vu aussi à
quel point on avait la capacité de
réussir à s'adapter en fait et à réussir
à sortir de situations où tout le monde
aurait pu dire les foutu on décale le
tournage de ces derniers non il ya des
bouts de bois et une canette de coca
macgyver le mulet banana banana on
répare tac on s'adapte et ça marche et
c'est tout le temps comme ça dans jdg
je pense qu'on serait pas arrivé là on
en est maintenant si on n'avait pas
réussi à s'adapter à toutes les
situations critiques
quand on était dans le forez fugère
notamment il ya un moment où il ya une
route de vieux qui est sorti de hand
entre les fougères justement
il faut réfugiés près de fougères qui
sont passés devant nous en mode mais
qu'est ce qui se passe mais regardez ces
petits jeunes là mais qu'est ce qu'ils
sont en train de tourner mais c'est
rigolo ils sont beaux costumes et
qui va m'arriver où on fait une pause et
donc ils ont pris des photos avec nous
alors qu'il savait pas du tout qui en
été mais ça c'était assez marrant mais
du coup c'est qu'ils ont des petits
enfants et qui leur montre mon dieu mais
c'est mathieu sommet mamie mais qu'est
ce que tu vois avec lui donc ça c'était
assez c'est assez rigolo
conclusion
c'est bien passé ne fait pas mieux que
je le pensais c'est que comme nous a
énormément aidés
c'est vrai qu'on a énormément pas la
planifier ça fait partie des rares
vidéos qu un story board l avance
d'habitude les vidéos ou les storyboards
jamais lala com c'est de la grosse mise
en scène on l'avait fait pour mass
effect par exemple là on la refait c'est
vrai que ça faisait partie des gros
projets qu'on voulait finir sur lâchait
sur la chaîne on avait fait un autre
gros projet on a commencé la 19e et
c'est vrai que j'ai vraiment très envie
de faire une disney deux savoie est donc
là rpg 3 ça faisait vraiment on voulait
vraiment qui est une conclusion voulait
pas laisser ça en plongeant au milieu de
rpg 260 king conclusion non bah moi je
suis vraiment content d'avoir tourné ça
parce que c'est ça aussi c'est ça aussi
les joueurs du grenier c'est aussi des
fois où on ce cas on se casse le cul au
delà de ce qu'on devrait faire même des
fois les gens qui disent mais n'ont pas
besoin la mise en scène on s'en fout
machin non venue tester que ça arrive
mais non parce qu'il faut il faut que
nous on se fasse plaisir aussi
et nous faire de la mise en scène ça
nous fait plaisir ça nous éclater
ça nous plaît et vraiment ça fait partie
des trucs aussi justement de ce qu'on
veut dégager sur cette chaîne c'est ya
des fois des vidéos un peu plus petit
des avec un peu moins de scénario mais
on veut aussi qui est des fois il ya des
10es la grosse vidéo avec vraiment plein
moyen ou vraiment je le dis cette vidéo
nous a carrément coûté quatre fois plus
qu'elle nous a rapporté un mais mais
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave et on
s'en fout on regarde pas à la dépense
parce que justement c'est ça aussi on
veut on veut montrer que que des fois on
se lâche et on fait vraiment tout pour
tous pour le public et pour que tout
pour que les gens ils se disent bella
[ __ ] là ils ont vraiment tout donné et
là c'est vraiment qu'on voulait vraiment
que les gens et ça non
dans leurs têtes quand ils sortent de la
vidéo qu'ils moi je viens de regarder
une vidéo mensuel sur internet et j'ai
l'impression d'avoir vu un casey
quasiment un mélange de courts métrages
et de test du jeu rétro et ses sorts
défend on veut aussi faire ce gros ce
genre de grosse grosse vidéo on veut
vraiment se donner du mal on veut
vraiment montrer qu'on aime ce qu'on
fait et ce en faisant ce genre de gros
projets qu'on montre vraiment qu'on aime
ce qu'on fait merci d'avoir regardé puis
j'espère que cette vidéo rpg 3 vous a
plu allez donc on est parti pour tourner
suivez le soleil va se
le soleil va se jeta
le soleil
[Musique]
[Rires]
le soleil va se coucher il faudrait se
représente affaire où la femme de toi
majeur
[Applaudissements]
je crois que mes sens de krump la
naissance de criant call of je crois que
mes sens de cambrioleurs strictement
humain m'indique d'un danger imminent
d'un un danger merde je crois qu'ils
veulent c'est dur ça va être très très
dur tous peeters s'est levé lunettes 3d
elf
je suis sylvain fils de sylvain roy dfw
[Applaudissements]
dans l'europe
baronnet mon nom dans la forêt des elfes
sylvains au maire fait chier [ __ ]
pensez vraiment
moteur et actions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une thérapie cours seuls mes amis
m'appellent comme ça on va faire plus au
nord de tokyo
un petit peu moins bon bah ouais je me
rappelle comme ça ça fait la deuxième
fois cette semaine
ça fait chier [ __ ] encore et mes
pompes
molly soient si rapides comme tu reste
moins longtemps fixé le communisme
vous n'êtes pas beau puppe duc et voilà
à s'excuser mais ce que vous vous
écartez un petit peu si on le fait au
ralenti
je l'avais jamais nous avons battu le
méchant libérer le château et la creuse
a à aa
ah ah ah
photo na waie
[Applaudissements]